por cuarta semana consecutiva de
manifestaciones en Irán
samantage la capital de la provincia de
kurdistán iraní sigue siendo uno de los
escenarios del levantamiento contra el
gobierno la ciudad está sometida a una
represión y a un bloqueo que la deja
prácticamente aislada de resto del mundo
pero estas imágenes verificadas por la
agencia de noticias asociated press dan
una idea de la situación
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos expresaron su
preocupación
amnistía internacional está alarmada por
la represión de las protestas en San
Andrés en la provincia del kurdistán
Irán culpa a los grupos de oposición
kurdos iraníes asentados en el kurdistán
iraquí
algunos son agentes del enemigo o si no
son agentes del enemigo entonces están
alineados con el enemigo con los mismos
objetivos salen a la calle la revuelta
en Irán comenzó el 16 de septiembre tras
la muerte de una mujer kurda masa a mini
después de su detención por la policía
de la moral enterarán la provincia del
curtistan es una región que
históricamente se ha enfrentado a la
República islámica de Irán ahí los
habitantes mayoritariamente Sony es son
regularmente discriminados esta semana
por primera vez desde que comenzaron las
protestas los trabajadores del complejo
petroquímico y de la refinería de
asaludge en el sur de Irán lanzaron una
protesta en apoyo de los manifestantes
es poco común que una huelga de
trabajadores se realicen apoyo de una
protesta pública las huelgas fueron una
de las herramientas que llevaron a la
revolución de 1979 y a la caída del chat
de Irán